hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine Damen
und Herren in letzter Zeit habt ihr mir
ziemlich häufig eine Website namens
lpsg zugeschickt ich habe mich darüber
mal so ein bisschen informiert habe
geschaut hey was steht das eigentlich
large
support group und bei dieser lpsg
Website geht es einfach nur schlecht weg
darum dass wenn man dort angemeldet ist
also ein Member dieses Forums ist man
beispielsweise Bilder hochladen kann von
einer Person die man im Internet
gefunden hat dann kann man z.B Fragen
hey hat jemand noch mehr Bilder von
dieser Person weiß jemand wie diese
Person heißt man kann sich austauschen
das alles aus seiner romantischen
Art und Weise
ich habe mich da natürlich gefragt warum
wird mir diese Webseite die ganze Zeit
zugeschickt was soll ich damit zu tun
haben es gibt einen concrafter Laser
Luca German Youtuber Forum Artikel dort
mit 65
Seiten der existiert seit mehr als 5
Jahren
und da sind aktiv
Leute am Start
Posten alle paar Tage
Bilder von mir rein
das anybody have anything on this German
Youtuber baby I would do anything
und dann postet er 7
Bilder von
mir aus den vergangenen sechs Jahren und
dieser Beitrag
gefällt auch noch
Personen menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend und wenn wir dann auf dieser
Website hier einfach mal so ein bisschen
runter scrollen sehen wir dass ein
anderer User tatsächlich dann auch fünf
Bilder von mir gepostet wie ich mit
Handschellen angekettet auf meinem Sofa
liege
das war keine Kranke Action für
irgendeinen keine Ahnung was für ein
Film sondern das war für eine
Kooperation für ein Video was ich damals
mit Max gedreht hatte ich weiß nicht ob
es für Spider-Man war aber für irgendein
Kinofilm
aber scrollen wir weiter
und sehen Bilder von mir im Pool
am Pool meine Eltern mit Namen
aufblasbaren Pizza Matratze wo ich ein
dumm Block gemacht habe Bild hochgeladen
habe
hier hier bei mir im Badezimmer
fällt auch wieder mehr als 30 Leuten
hier geht's dann weiter mit Bildern von
mir wie ich am Strand stehe in der
Badewanne setze sechs Jahre her oder so
hier wo ich mit Max damals vor sieben
acht Jahren in Wales auf einem Trip war
hier saß hier in Berlin in der Badewanne
hier war ich wieder im Pool also
relativ normale Bilder hier geht es dann
weiter mit Bildern wie ich in Vlogs
unter der Dusche stehe hier wie ich ein
Bild von Justin Bieber nachgestellt habe
hier hat meine Fußball Challenge gedreht
damals 36 Grad deswegen hatten wir so
oben ohne gemacht alle hier waren wir am
Strand unterwegs auch im Strandurlaub
das ist logisch dass man bei einer
Badehose natürlich auch kein T-Shirt an
hat
ja und dann werden da so Kommentare
immer drunter geschrieben wie z.B an
Sensor
oder
catfish Tim und Ex auf his
News
because we will probably never get to
see them
der gleiche User hat dann auch noch mal
diese Bilder
von mir gepostet ich habe damals
versucht
Instagram Post von Pamela reif
nachzustellen bei try to catfish Himmel
while go but you never replight a friend
of mine female matthim in the club in
Cologne and sad the tea is very Aragons
for those no German youtubers erhält
catfishing KS Freak Alex V in Serkan
from SKK zu if you wanna see the news
just die Emmy i want post
it is red von Luca also diese Person ist
anscheinend ein deutscher schreibt euch
das aus Köln kommt
hat wohl eine Freundin die mich damals
vor 5 Jahren in einem Club in Köln
getroffen hat die meinte ich sei sehr
arrogant gewesen
[Musik]
ich bin einfach 9 Leuten gegenüber sehr
sehr vorsichtig und möchte eigentlich
wenn jemand was zu tun haben außer mit
meinen Freunden deswegen wenn man das so
interpretiert in Ordnung aber allein die
Tatsache dass er hier so über mich
urteilt auf der anderen Seite allerdings
sagt dass er mich catfischen wollte also
er wollte mich anscheinend verarschen
das heißt er hat sich wahrscheinlich ein
Fake Profil bei Instagram erstellt mit
Bildern von einem hübschen Mädchen weil
er weiß dass ich heterosexuell bin hat
mich dann wahrscheinlich angeschrieben
und wollte von mir irgendwie Nacktbilder
raus gelockt haben
ich gehe halt nicht auf meine Instagram
die haben es eigentlich ich bin nie in
meinen DMS unterwegs sowas es ist
ziemlich weird dieser Ordner bei mir ich
will damit gar nichts zu tun haben
allerdings ist es halt einfach eine
Straftat die er hier gerade zu er sagt
auch er hat das bei anderen Youtubern
gemacht und er also das ist etwas
und da drunter
oder dann einen Beitrag wieder gepostet
von diesem Android der angeblich selber
hier aus Köln komme wo ich auch herkomme
und der angeblich meinte dass er mich
schon mal catfischen wollte der hat dann
nämlich geschrieben schert nudes within
die ja dann gepostet hat
und das bin nicht ich diese nudes haben
dann auch irgendwie 129 likes jemand
fragt dann auch bist du dir sicher dass
das ist und er schreibt 100% Schuhe
snaped within yesterday catfished
ich schwöre
auf meine Familie
auf mein ganzes Leben auf alles dass ich
niemals mit diesem Typen
irgendwie Kontakt hatte ich habe noch
nie irgendwelche News rausgeschickt also
ich finde es so brutal wie er sich hier
selbst irgendwie als den Held dieser
lpsg-szene darstellt mit irgendwelchen
Lügen was ist denn los in letzter Zeit
er schreibt ja auch noch dass er mir als
Mädchen gesnappt hat und er meint dass
ich 100% straight bin das ist die erste
wahre Aussage von ihm daraufhin schreibt
jemand dittisenthumor als Special die
assetproof that he is real also mäßig
hat er noch mehr geschickt als Beweis
dafür dass es wirklich real ist weil man
sieht allein schon ich kann euch die
Bilder nicht ein wenn aber man sieht so
ein Bauch und halt noch andere Sachen
man sieht allein daran schon dass das
gar nicht sein kann mein Bauch sieht
komplett anders aus meiner Hand sie
komplett anders aus aber ist ja auch
egal ich muss mich hier von jemandem
rechtfertigen für irgendwas was nicht
existiert oder was ich nicht gemacht
habe das sind muss ich in letzter Zeit
ein bisschen häufiger machen
es gab auch diese eine Sache auf tiktok
die komplett wo ich mir dachte wo greift
ihr sowas jetzt her so ich will niemand
irgendwie eine Aufmerksamkeit geben der
versucht mich irgendwie fertig machen
weil es ist einfach nicht möglich mit
Lügen das geht einfach nicht genau so
jetzt diese Sache das weiß nicht schlimm
aber diese Anna Striegel davon gemacht
hat wo sie mich anscheinend trotzdem
wollte was auch nicht geklappt hat so
hä dieser Andrew aus Köln hat dann auf
jeden Fall geantwortet die schaut ist
face in one snap but I didn't safe that
Andrew hast du angeblich alles gesichert
außer das einzige Bild was beweisen
könnte dass ich das war
und dann schreibt auch noch dieser
Lennart also der Ersteller aus Holland
Amsterdam von dieser ganzen dread-seite
wo man irgendwie diese Bilder von mir
hochladen kann der schreibt dann auch
noch auf die Nachricht von diesem
Android mit diesem gefakten Bildern oh
mein Gott ist das wirklich eher hast du
irgendwas an Beweisen wie ein Screenshot
vom Chat oder so das wird mein Tag so
viel besser machen wenn das wirklich er
wäre
also erstmal traurig was deine Tage
anscheinend besser macht und würde ich
auch mal gerne sehen wenn ein Screenshot
vom Chat hätte oMG so hot do you get
more he so hot anything more hier ist so
hot hot und dieses Foto einfach
angehangen ich habe geschrieben war
gerade im Pool mit komplett falschen
deutschen dann einfach mein Hals
fotografiert hä hier schreibt jetzt
allerdings jemand Heili dort ist him
just check out to the left Office belly
button in the first election
Luca da sind have anywhere aah endlich
mal jemand der vielleicht ein bisschen
vergleicht und schaut
sieht irgendwie gar nicht aus wie er zu
Bett ist ugly girlfriend is now in every
Video also nicht nur nehmen sich die
User dieser Website das Recht raus
Bilder von mir hier zu veröffentlichen
die dann irgendwelchen Creeps als
Vorlage genutzt werden
sie nehmen sich dazu auch noch das Recht
raus mich catfisch und verarschen zu
wollen was nicht geklappt hat ich habe
ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr mitbekommen
aber es wird auch so nicht klappen ich
war eigentlich nie auf irgendwie sowas
rein und bin bei allen Sachen
abgesichert und wird auch generell darum
geht's doch gar nicht aber zu allem
Überfluss beleidigen sie jetzt auch noch
meine Ex-Freundinnen
mir fällt nichts mehr dazu ich kann euch
nur sagen wie Unternehmen gerade schon
rechtliche Schritte und klären uns da ab
wie wir irgendwie dagegen vorgehen
können hier weil ich das einfach
bodenlos finde ich weiß dass so
Forenbetreiber immer sehr oft rechtlich
juristisch gesehen und alle Richtungen
abgesichert sind weil die sich immer
damit rausreden zu sagen hey wir bieten
nur die Plattform das was die Leute
hochladen können wir nichts für aber das
funktioniert halt so nicht dann musst du
das halt schließen
[Musik]
boah ne nächstes mal bitte ohne Hose
ey sorry ich beende an der Stelle das
Video ich lade hoch was ich möchte wenn
ich meinen Körper zeigen möchte dann
mache ich das ich werde aber nicht mehr
zeigen ich werde niemals machen ich
werde niemals in irgendeine Richtung
gehen die alle haben wollen das ist hier
Beitrag 1291 auf dieser Seite wo es um
diese Bilder von mir geht wir gehen
gerade richtig dagegen vor ich habe
keinen Bock dass sowas kursiert ich
möchte dafür bekannt sein was ich für
dumm lustigen vielleicht unterhaltsamen
Content auf Youtube mache und nicht
sowas deswegen gerade gegen diese Sachen
wo Leute halt über die strafrechtliche
Schwelle gesprungen sind versuche mir
gerade strafrechtlich gegen vorzugehen
ich ähm wollte dem ganzen Thema
eigentlich keine Aufmerksamkeit geben
aber ich glaube es ist der richtige Weg
um einfach nur kurz Clip und klar zu
sagen dass sowas das bodenlos ist dass
man irgendwie machen kann
klar es gibt ganz viele große andere
Probleme auf der Welt aber
ich will jetzt nicht so eine Diskussion
anfangen mich mich nervt einfach nur
extrem sowas auch immer hey ich traue
mich gar nicht mehr wenn ich im Jim bin
irgendwie zu Filmen nicht trainiere weil
man an meine Füße sieht mit Socken und
so und dann kriege ich immer hunderte
Nachrichten von Leuten die sagen ey hier
meine Socken Foto Sammlung von dir hey
verkauft seinen Job für 500 € ey lass
mich bitte einfach alle in Ruhe okay
morgen geht's weiter mit einem normalen
video
es war jetzt mehr realtalk als dass das
hier keiner irgendwas anderes war aber
boah